um
all right let's take that one out that
was a search
so we've got the reality of marriage
here
okay so this is a marriage one let's do
this one uh share
share screen
and chrome tab disadvantage of marriage
and there we go
like you know it's it's it's funny
because these things are all over um the
internet ticktop um you know like
youtube there's all these like dedicated
channels
um that are decentralized all over the
web right now
that are that are putting out these
sound bites and clips but they're all
affiliate link back to like products
that are being sold but like dude is a
genius marketer when it comes to
building
uh reach you know stuff like this
he's done he's done probably a better
job than anybody else out there that
i've seen myself included if you know if
your goal is getting to more people
uh okay so let's pull up volume on this
one
and hit play are you gonna get married
i'd never get married why not i don't
see i don't see the tactical advantage
if i decided to be loyal to a woman and
be with her forever that's fine if i
decide to have children with a woman
that's fine i decided to have a house
with a woman live with her sure possible
it's not optimal but it's possible but
the idea of just getting married in and
of itself is completely not only
fruitless i think it's for the woman the
women enjoy it but women enjoy lots of
things when they do not pay for organize
anything sure she's off on instagram
organized nothing wastes all my money
and now the government's involved in a
new area of my life i don't know what
the government involved the government
is already involved in when i register a
car all my money a bank account when i
get a job i want to buy a house
government's everywhere right don't i
just want to at least be able to walk
around my dick without the government
being involved now if i put my dick in
another [ __ ] my wife can go and say i
have proof you put a stick another [ __ ]
go to a lawyer and go to the government
he owes me this input that's adultery
automatic this box percent the the so
now the government is watching my dick
are you gonna get married over
right so i have an entire chapter in my
um book guys i know many of you have
read if you haven't it's on amazon the
unplugged alpha that deals specifically
with uh marriage um i have a video on my
i think unplugged alpha podcast in the
last
90 days perhaps
and i was talking about why i would
never get married um all the
all the things that he state there are
really just the tip of the iceberg i
mean there's a lot more to it than just
that but again that's offensive this one
here has
uh 5.2 million views um on just one tick
tock video there's probably like
multiple clips of the exact same video
in different parts of the internet as
well so you know the extra views that
come out of that but the point that i'm
making is people get offended by stuff
like this uh i bet if we go to the
comments uh true if he marries a wrong
woman okay
stupid comment right because you know
he's never been in real life
uh i'm sure i'm sure that we'll see
something like uh you know who who hurt
him or he's got a small pp let's see if
we get something he's just afraid yeah
uh damn bro now i'm not gonna get
married uh fax so like the dudes are for
the most part agreeing with it
um
nobody cares says a happy marriage is
one of the best things
um so i mean you're gonna get a lot from
the opposite side basically saying like
what's wrong with this guy uh this one
here says he's got commitment issues
um let's look for the ones with the
female avatars
and it's
playing again on my earphones
uh
marriage is a bond to be legal to be
legally remain with one person forever
that means he doesn't want to be with
one woman forever
no i mean the argument that he's making
and and he's stating quite clear like i
have no problem
inviting a woman in my life and having
children with her right he stated that
very very clearly he just doesn't want
the government to get involved in his
life and the reason why women want
marriage is because they have that extra
security blanket because men play to win
women play not to lose in life
especially when it comes to stuff like
this so women know there's an advantage
to inviting the state into their
household
because everything in family law is
written to protect her
in case things don't work out whether he
decides to bounce on her and abandon the
family or she decides to abandon the
family which is seven times out of ten
what happens like women initiate
divorces it's something like seven or
eight times out of ten um you know men
do it very very rarely
uh lucky no woman wants to marry him
says emma right so it's so it's a lot of
women that are all here in the um chat
basically saying you know this guy's
hurt essentially so let's take that out
um okay here's another clip i found on
the topic of marriage which
i think it's an older one because
he's sitting in a 720 um because it
hurts you're feeling big facts which one
is this
okay because it hurts your feelings
there we go audio tab
okay here we go
they great on me and they piss me off
but the ones when i say a few i mean a
lot there are a lot of things which
bother me they're great on me and they
piss me off but the one that's probably
up there that annoys me the most is she
said yes
i [ __ ] hate
when men say that oh my god she said yes
why are you with a [ __ ] that would say
no
why are you with the woman
paying for her dinner sleeping next to
her every night not [ __ ] all these
hoes not cheating behaving yourself
coming home not hanging out with the
boys you're doing all this [ __ ] for that
[ __ ] and you're not a thousand percent
sure she would say yes and you're
sitting there going i hope i hope she
says yes
and then if she does you're happy
let me tell you something there ain't a
[ __ ] alive there ain't a [ __ ] i've
[ __ ] in the last 10 years who wouldn't
say yes to me after getting [ __ ] once
[ __ ] the relationship i can sleep with
any [ __ ]
out here one solitary time and say we're
gonna get married and you know what
she's gonna say okay
yes of course she'll say yes why are you
[ __ ] surprised if a man is surprised
or doubtful she might say yes or elated
that he is lucky enough that she said
yes to taking half of his stuff when
they break up then he is a [ __ ]
okay
so
this is something that i've talked with
my inner circle about privately and it's
like you'll see it on social media often
she said yes
um another one of my favorites is when
it's like a birthday or it's mother's
day or something like this and the dude
puts her up on a pedestal and he's like
oh she's my son and my moon and my stars
and my night and day and the best mother
and wife and best friend and blah blah
blah and also
and then you kind of you know because
she's always tagged and then you click
through and then you see what what's
going on her social and his is like him
and her or him her and the family or him
her and the kids sort of thing and you
click through on her and it's like an
instagram butt model pic sort of like
that you know sort of thing and it's
like
the dude is like putting her up on a
pedestal and there's no evidence that
she even wants to acknowledge his
existence the same thing with the he
says you know like she said yes sort of
narrative
exactly what he's saying there is why
would you want to deal with a woman that
wouldn't say yes like why are you
celebrating
that you're proposing to her and that
she said yes and it's like she said yes
in big bold fonts and i get it because
you know we live in a feminized society
women come first the feminine comes
first and a lot of women run dudes and
it's like as soon as they engage even
they'll be uh email crafted that has to
be edited for 48 hours um you know we
have to make sure we got all the right
you know people see seed on it so it
goes to the group there's a photograph
um you know like a retake of him
proposing to her down on his knee sort
of thing and it's like you know the
caption is i said yes or something like
that so
this is very common today right and all
the dudes really saying is like why
would you want to deal with a check that
wouldn't say yes right like what exactly
is it that you're celebrating so it's a
fair point right i mean like again where
is a lie like what is what is so
controversial about that exactly
is what i'm confused about
uh what is this one here uh big facts oh
this is a single mom one so let's play
that one um
also have a chapter in my book on
why guys should avoid that
uh we'll talk about that a little bit
more so big facts boom here we go
and where's volume
and then they break off pull this off
yes i lived
to moscow for a while right oh you in
russia a woman with a child ain't gonna
get a dude
she ain't gonna get a guy so the reason
they break up less the reason the women
stick by the men the reason women are
more loyal is because five times she has
that man's kid her chance of leaving and
dating somebody else is [ __ ] zero so
unless her man's still basically paying
them i just noticed the amount of music
that they play in the background on all
these tick tocks it's pretty annoying
bill's all right he cheats he does what
he does but he's home twice a week and
the bill's paid she ain't got nowhere
else to [ __ ] go because the idea of
being a single mother and getting a man
in my place like russia is zero you come
here to america and it's just like oh
yeah you're right you should take him to
school dude i don't owe that
[ __ ] nothing so
i mean the point he's making basically
is here in the west north america canada
england you know for example united
states
they'll celebrate you you'll get the
government will take care of you if um
you have a dude's kid and he's fairly
well off the family law system will make
sure that you've got plenty of his
financial resources to take care of
things they won't guarantee the father
can have access to the kid or even spend
much time with them but they'll
guarantee that his financial resources
do go to her and you know the point that
he's making is in other parts of the
world um russia i would imagine like
asia china japan africa probably
um
you know they're not celebrated like
single motherhood's not celebrated the
way that it is in the west
and
like i've you know i've said from my own
personal experience why would you want
to get involved why would you want to
invite that in your life but let's let's
keep playing this room
[Music]
my man can run around and impregnate
four [ __ ] and then some other dudes
come along taking his kids to sleep
you know what i'm saying i hate that guy
i know neither am i
so you you feel me no neither am i yo it
is plaguing me and then you know what
you're gonna get ashamed with the term
of you got a little big energy oh bro
listen i mean dude you have a little
dick energy you don't have confidence
confidence now they're re-branding it
they rebranded it to be just gonna
scroll down and see what's uh
it's like playing another guy's story on
save mode we've seen that one a thousand
times if you've been around the space
louis says nigeria is like that too
uh this dude says i tried it ain't worth
the kids uh amazing moms just too much
trauma
uh this chick over here says i bet
mothers of these guys who are talking a
very are very proud of she can't even
use proper grammar
dude says he ain't wrong
uh unfortunately
he don't have to but if he do it should
be very much appreciated
should be very much a pre iran is like
that too facts facts facts facts yeah
you know it's always you know it's
always the standard sort of stuff right
i mean like what's in it for the guy
right like what is the benefit to that
um
i'm going to grab the join link for you
guys because i know some of you are like
salivating to come in and have a
conversation on this um copy
the invite link and let's put it on
uh so again if you guys are watching
somewhere else on the interwebs uh head
over to the unplugged alpha youtube
channel subscribe there hit the like
button we've got just over 200 likes and
way more than that people watching come
on guys
like it costs nothing hit the like
button get get the likes up for the
algorithms come on um
come on in and ask a question and that's
only going to be pinned on the youtube
channel for the employee alpha that's
the stream yard link
so make sure you got a good internet
connection ideally headphones or you're
in an area where you're not going to get
feedback and screw up my stream
if you know what i'm saying
um
okay what's the next one we got here i
got three more and then we'll get to the
q and a stuff
all right so we got um this one here
with uh i can't remember what this
podcast was called it was like whatever
the the city boys or something like that
again it was hilarious
um
dude's funny as hell i i would i would
totally sit down and have a drink with
this guy like he's he's he's funny he's
i mean i've talked to him privately
offline a lot more than i've done
um
air broadcast with andrew i think he's a
cool guy it's just like you know
he rubs people the wrong way because
he's bombastic he's loud you know he
says you know he says [ __ ] that hurts
people's feelings obviously
all right so let's turn up the volume
here and
this is i guess we're talking about
promise so would you be with me if i'd
slept with over 50 men
i'm a high value woman right
you said it yourself how can you be high
value
for 50 minutes
i've just been single for a long time oh
unacceptable why is it unacceptable
a body count is probably the number one
most easiest way to judge the value of a
female so would you be with
yeah um
what is it on my red flag list
number 11 big notch counts
um
statistically speaking
because i mean generally speaking most
guys that i talk to when they want to
deal with women they're want to deal
with them like not just for like a
one-night stand it's like kind of like
they want to deal with a woman on a
long-term basis they either want to have
kids they want to get married they want
to be in a relationship whatever it
happens to be
but
all the predictors of anything
good on a long-term basis go right down
the toilet
when her notch count goes up her notch
count goes up the
the all the indicators say this is going
to go south quickly
lower probability of her being able to
pair bond to you higher probability of
divorce
uh divorce rape taking your kids
um depression single motherhood
abortions like you can go right down the
list right and this isn't me saying this
this is facts this is this is university
studies that have been completed
uh studying the habits of human
promiscuity
um
and then the argument that people make
is well you know if men do it too blah
blah blah sort of thing it's like you
know the fact of the matter is it
doesn't affect men the same way that
affects women let's see what they're
saying in the the comments here
uh cats have nine lives her one life is
dead
um
a chick says by that logic he's also not
high value again you know like what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander right like you know this is this
is very very common um
narratives today where
you know women are like well if guys can
do it then women can too and it's like
yeah you can do whatever you want today
you know you've got in fact more rights
than men right um
facts right you know you've got more
rights than men today so
one of the
clips that i came across i'm not sure if
i have it here in the next two that are
left over i think last two are on
depression um with something along the
lines of um
you know uh
well
i'll get into it when i get into the
depression action once or so i'll save
it for that but um yeah there's a lot of
a lot of people that are still saying
like you know like well women can do it
too and it's like yeah you can but
you're going to probably ruin yourself
at the end of the day you're not going
to be able to pair bond to a guy you're
a lousy choice for a guy
uh to invite into your life if they want
to raise a family and have kids
especially with the hostile family law
because what usually ends up happening
is
these women will just run through a
whole bunch of guys and they'll get to
like 30 and they'll be like okay the
clock's ticking i got to start you know
pounding out some kids now so i'm going
to find god and you know get get right
with everything and find a good guy and
no high high value alpha male that you
know she was interested in the past
wants anything to do with her so she
finds some like
fairly successful beta guy that she's
not that attracted to and i can't tell
you how many conversations i've had now
with both men and women telling me
either themselves or they know somebody
personally that they're in a sexless
marriage right and it's not because he
doesn't want to bang her it's because
she doesn't want to want to touch him
and they've already got a kid or two or
three or something like that or you know
maybe like another one on the way sort
of thing and he gets so pissed off that
he ends up like you know either going
outside of the marriage or leaving
ultimatum on it and then he gets blamed
for everything right because he doesn't
have the patience for it but the fact
the matter is she was so enthusiastic in
her 20s with all the other alpha dudes
that she got stuck with this loser let's
just call him
because he was good enough and he was
wealthy and then she figures out oh wait
you know family law is going to be good
to me if i take the kids that run
because he's he makes a lot of money he
works you know he's owns a business or
he's whatever cfo cto something like
that
and then you know the money just kind of
flows to her and then she goes and finds
his alpha dudes again she goes back to
her party years again in her you know
her mid to late 30s
so
what he's stating is you know complete
facts right i mean
like a woman with a high notch count is
not valuable to a man men are inherently
disgusted by women that have been with a
lot of guys facts of life i mean it's
why you know for
thousands of years uh you know virginity
was so highly valued right i mean i was
looking at some stats a about a week ago
because i'm because i'm working on my
next book i'm just you know going
through all the chapters and i'm adding
some more of the uh stuff that i need to
talk about and there was this one um you
know piece of data they came across so i
was born in the 70s and in the 70s the
chance of you marrying a virgin was
somewhere in the 20 range like 20 25 you
know something you know something like
that it would have been a lot higher
back in the 30s or 40s or something like
that but they didn't appear to collect
the data then because it was kind of
just a given you know i would imagine
but today the chance you're marrying for
sure less than like three percent like
in 2022 the chances of you marrying are
are that low like it's like you know
we've gone from it was it was common
um in my grandparents era too it's very
very uncommon today right so anyway you
know it's a fact of life is what it is
so let's pull that out and we'll do the
last two here which i think are on
depression so
he gets uh hammered on that for
uh so this is destroy's oldest fortnight
player which i think is kind of funny
actually so let's share this one share
screen chrome tab
um
like you know in some cases the jokes
write themselves
um
i don't know if you can see this guy
here let's go bigger on the screen here
i don't know if you can see this dude
that he's going to talk to over here uh
but he says i am the oldest pro
fortnight player indeed and he's sitting
there um
looking like your typical
like soy avatar pink hair
anyway so let's just play it check it
out
player indeed and and dude i have
nothing personal against you andrew just
pulled back i'm sorry
i am the oldest pro fortnite player
indeed and and dude i have nothing
personal against you andrew but like
though
some of your philosophy i don't think
you're a [ __ ] i think you're a water
boy you know
water boy for patriarchy and capitalism
and whatnot right and sort of regressive
ideas about manhood
and uh which is why the teenager
i just i just want to pause this for a
sec a guy with pink hair
okay is lecturing a kickboxing champion
on masculinity like
again you know sometimes the jokes just
write themselves man you just have to
sit back and like pause the screen and
have a laugh
which audience like consumes it so much
you know you got these young boys that
are like grappling with feelings of
powerlessness and you come in and offer
them like how to be a man but you're
just you're so off base for
it's like it's tragic really
so
you think that i am inspiring the youth
of today
the masculine youth of today to become
men and you think that's a negative
thing why why no i don't i don't think
you're inspiring them to become men
because like real men are in touch with
their emotions
and their vulnerability and
don't need to be like wielding and
taking power
does this dude not have a mirror in his
house that he looks at every morning uh
like i just don't understand this man it
just doesn't make any sense
real men are self-aware yeah i've let
you talk now it's my turn this whole
patriarchy [ __ ] you're saying are
outdated ideas of masculinity yeah the
idea of patriarchy is not an outdated
idea of masculinity perhaps in the west
in a declining empire as we've already
discussed on this stream and an empire
which is an absolute decline you can
have men who sit here and think there's
absolutely nothing necessary about
masculinity in the modern world and that
you don't need to be strong or brave or
any of these things you can sit around
and cry and you're still a man that is
not true in most places on the planet in
most places on the planet men need to be
capable and competent because they don't
they do not survive and i'll tell you
something now sir i'll tell you
something else now you will sit here and
talk all talk right now about the
patriarchy and how you can be in touch
with your feelings and all this [ __ ]
the second you're physically assaulted
or physically threatened the first thing
you do is you call a toxicly masculine
police officer to turn up with a weapon
to protect you because you cannot
protect yourself you are not against the
idea of masculine power you're not
against the idea of men who have
masculine imperatives to defense all
you've done is outsource it to someone
else to do at the end of a phone call
because you're too scared to do it
yourself so you're [ __ ] lying you're
alive
you don't want to do them yourself and
you hope everyone else does them for you
so you can sit around and play [ __ ]
video games
so
checkmate right i mean um
comments who's who's the woman with the
pink hair uh
dude lost me when he said he was a
fortnight pro
right i mean like again you know
sometimes the jokes just write
themselves but it's like
the idea that somebody like this i guess
it's on twitch uh i don't know twitch or
whatever that streaming platform is you
know for the gamers you know sort of
thing is a
big uh big popular area and you know
these guys just found them because of
some of the clips that uh
you know they picked up on from the tick
tocks and they invited him on the stream
and it's like you know look at the face
of the kid on the bottom who's the young
one and he's like
watching tate destroy the pink-haired
uh western male
who's basically saying that men need to
get in touch with their emotions it's
like
the notions that are being sold as
widely accepted today
of
just tuning your emotions bro you know
like you're you're you're serving guys
the wrong way bro with my pink hair like
dude's about the same age as me
playing fortnite professionally
lecturing on masculinity to a guy that
can beat living crap out of pretty like
i want to see the fight between uh jake
paul or whoever paul was going to fight
him when
you know like tate called him out a
couple years ago and fought him and from
what i understand like one or two of the
paul brothers have accepted i want to
see that fight go down i think that
would be interesting listening to this
conversation between him and the pink
hair dude not that interesting it's like
you know like there's no argument like
you would just literally need to just
shut up not say anything and just be
like okay talk you know because you just
really just proven my point
um all right last one and then we'll get
to some of the call-ins again the link
for the call-ins is pinned in the
unplugged alpha stream so
it's free to call in to talk about
whatever you guys want right um chrome
tab and let's do depression is not real
so let's talk let's talk about
depression because i know he's been uh
crucified for this one for years now
do you know how many people stuck up for
depression you don't understand i'm
depressed sorry i just want to make sure
the volume is loud enough you guys can
hear it let me back it up
and you know what's crazy when i said
this depression thing wasn't real do you
know how many people stuck up for
depression you don't understand i'm
depressed depression's real that i was
like if it's so horrible why are you
defending it you sound like it's a pr
team
i thought it was ruining your life but
you are desperate for me to believe it
you want me to believe in it you're
sticking up for it you're defending
depression trying to convince me it's
real because it's your pure all excuse
for failure when you're depressed you
can fail in every human metric i fail at
everything but i'm depressed it's not my
goal no you're a failure that's all you
are
all right so
let's see what the comments say here do
you just cure me this actually makes
sense it's real but no excuse so people
get really pissed off when
you start saying that depression ain't
real
um
i believe it's a misalignment with your
expectations like if you have an
expectation that isn't met and you don't
get what you want that's when people
start to play like the victim card
depression oh my fees are hurt sort of
stuff like that and
when it comes to
society and humanity
i
look
i get it there's roads we have
electricity we're streaming this and we
can interact and i can click people in
and i can talk to somebody on the other
side of the world we have technology
today it's you know it's cool [ __ ]
awesome
but at the end of the day we're still
just meatballs like we're we're we're
meat covered skeletons on a rock flying
around a nuclear exploding [ __ ] thing
in the middle of the universe right and
if you think that we're that much
different from the animal kingdom
because we have cell phones and screens
and you know stuff like that you're
sadly mistaken take a look around the
animal kingdom and you tell me if
animals get depressed you tell me if a
lion gets sad because he hasn't eaten in
a couple of days no the lion's like i'm
hungry i don't eat grass i'm not going
to lower my standards so i'm going to go
find something to eat or i'm going to
die right and you know that would weed
out the weak but now we live in a
society today where we embrace weakness
you know where we embrace victimhood and
you know uh
like
look guys there's gonna be an entire
chapter in my next book that's that's
going to deal with the consequences of
of the choices that have been made in
society i'm not going to get into
specific details in this cast i'm just
going to leave it for the book but the
consequences that we're going to be
dealing with and are dealing with right
now because of what the global elites
you know have been leading people
believe and lie to us about in the
mainstream media
it's a fact of life we're a lot weaker
than our grandparents were we know for a
fact that men's testosterone levels are
in the toilet because they can tell
based on things like bone length of
index finger to middle finger
when they excavate from dig sites they
can tell by
bone structure in the jaw line because
skelet you know skeletons they don't
dissolve they're always there right so
they can tell what testosterone levels
were you know with a 500 year old
skeleton with a thousand year old
skeleton with a 5 000 year old skeleton
they can tell and today they're much
much lower than what they were in the
past and i'm telling you we've we've
become weaker as a species on this
planet
he's saying you know depression is not
real it's real i like like people that
say that they're depressed they actually
think that they're depressed but the
point that i believe that he's making
here you know like realistically is if
you point back to the animal kingdom
i've
you won't see a depressed lion you won't
see a depressed gazelle you'll see in a
live gazelle or a dead one you'll see in
a live lion or a dead one you'll see one
sleeping you'll see when chasing another
animal like this is how the animal
kingdom works they don't have time to
sit around and be like oh i'm depressed
i don't like the taste of this grass
over here where when i was at the
watering hole that alligator looked at
bob the wrong way and uh you know i
think he might have been racist because
you know he didn't you know he didn't
take a nibble at bob but he went for
becky instead sort of thing like
they don't do that we only do that in
society as human beings which is weird
right
so i mean it's like saying depression
isn't isn't real
what's
really happening is people
think that their experience
is depression and that it is real but
truth of matter is it's manufactured man
that's why it ain't real hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you